what is up there reject nation we are
here today to now rank the batman actors
the live-action theatrical versions of
them you might have caught our ranking
the batman movies list and within the
time of filming that video i've
rewatched some batman movies and believe
it or not this list on my end might
surprise you before we go into that why
don't you guys leave a like let's just
swing into it then shall we john you
want to kick us off sure i would love to
uh and the number seven spot for me is a
batman who i thought was actually a
really great casting choice but doesn't
really amount to much more than that and
that would be good old george clooney i
feel like there's a lot about his
persona that lends itself very well to
bruce wayne there are aspects of his
performance i do like i feel like he
showed up i just don't necessarily think
that he put a unique character spin on
bruce batman beyond his george clooney
charms which lend themselves more to
bruce than batman so that's why he lands
in my bottom spot could not disagree
more with you john george clooney's my
number one i'm swirling it ahead of you
guys no i would definitely say george
clooney's like the bottom of the bottom
for everything that you said yes and the
main reason why is because whatever
goodwill george clooney had for this
movie it is just completely overshadowed
by all the crap surrounding that film to
the point where i don't know what was
good about george clooney being in this
film other than the fact that it might
have sounded good on paper to this day
like an older bruce wayne george clinton
like i could see it it leaves like no
impression it actually comes across as
the most bland to me and makes his
performance just a mockery of batman
even though i don't feel like his
intention while filming it was
ultimately that it's kind of just
wrapped in a schumacher mess is the way
i would put it i feel we'll be all lined
up until we're at the top three then
we'll see where we're at okay what's
your number my number six is val kilmer
for a specific reason because in
re-watching batman forever which landed
towards the very bottom of my batman
movie's ranking list one pleasant
surprise out of that was i actually
really like val kilmer as bruce wayne
not as much as batman i feel like when
he's batman it's actually a little
distracting or there's something about
him that doesn't really quite match with
the whole persona he's trying to put on
as batman but as bruce wayne i was
actually quite endeared to him and i
really like the take that he is really
intent on you know philanthropy he does
seem more like a reclusive and a you
know just guy rather than like hey
playboy and i like that take on him so i
thought val kilmer as bruce was quite
nice but you know given sort of all the
other asterisks surrounding that movie
and the fact that i don't love his
batman as much i would put him in this
second to last spot i thought we'd be a
line for a little bit longer i'm
surprised my number six is actually
batman forever's valk kilmer uh yeah val
kilmer
val kilmer in this it's interesting
because when i was taking a look at some
clips again i was trying to pinpoint
what it was about belle kilmer in this
movie that is just not quite working for
me granted i think what he does is a
much bigger leap than
george clooney and batman and robin but
i really think this comes down to again
the joel schumacher vision because i
feel like val kilmer is actually doing
the best he can do given the
circumstances and that's part of what
weirdly makes some of his batman scenes
unintentionally funny is because he's
doing his best to take this seriously
because of the kind of movie it is i
can't take it as serious as the movie
wants me to however the leg up that i
would actually weirdly give on the
portrayal of bruce wayne batman in
batman forever versus the two
installments that came before directed
by tim burton this actually feels more
about bruce wayne and batman than those
other two films did so in that aspect
like what you were saying about bruce
wayne i do like that we explored a
little bit about him he's rarely going
into like therapy sessions this time
around so i like what he was doing as
bruce wayne however his batman i think
it's maybe the lips i think the lips are
a little too glossy there's something
about them lips that just makes me go i
can't take this seriously and you you
come across more like a bro dressed as
batman than you do as a serious menacing
guy like i don't believe the crazy dude
underneath there the god the crazy guy
that batman has to be underneath the
mask i'm a little afraid that we might
divert sooner than expected because uh
my number five i deliberated hard and i
was just like go with your heart john so
my number five is ben affleck i think he
does a really solid portrayal of bruce
wayne and batman i i really like him in
that role i just don't have the same
attachment to it that everybody else
does i feel like once we got to zack
snyder's justice league that was when i
was finally like i see what everybody
else sees and i care about this guy to
the degree that everybody else does but
given that it took a long time to get
there and it took so much kind of
sifting through these alternate cuts
which isn't really his performance's
fault but even in the bvs ultimate
edition i was like i like him i'm just
not like attached in any particular way
and so due to that i think i mean he's
miles better and more well-rounded than
a george clooney or a val kilmer but
there are you know just things about him
that don't draw me in and touch me
personally as a viewer as much but i
think he still is a great choice and if
he was to continue beyond the flash
movie i would be thrilled to see that
you're going to get a lot of agreements
on that that's all you'd expect i'm
going to make sure to call this video
restore the snyder verse ranking all the
batman movies
to make sure you're okay of course now
my number five would be adam west in
batman the 166
666 i think what adam west is doing here
ranks above val kilmer and george
clooney simply because it is intentional
that whole comedic performance that dry
deadpan type of delivery he inhabits the
world like he's the perfect batman to
compliment that world of the 60s batman
it's fun when you watch his interviews
with people like robert pattinson and
jeffrey wright who are like i actually
grew up on that batman
show and i didn't think it was funny at
the time like i took it serious i
thought there were like real stakes when
i watched that i don't know what it's
like to be plucked into that time period
and watch that show i grew up in the 60s
i would still think it was funny or
would i take it serious regardless his
version of batman while not my favorite
i think perfectly inhabits what that
world is and it's the best lead you
could ask for for
batman in that version absolutely and
that segues perfectly into my next spot
because my next spot would be adam west
and i agree with everything you said and
i think also too looking at his
portrayal of bruce wayne and batman i
mean there is a quirkiness there
obviously that is straight out of that
60s serial vibe but there's something
about the way that he's able to pin that
together like the further we get into
these adaptations the more we explore
the sort of interplay between bruce and
batman and the more we explore the idea
that he's probably not like a
well-adjusted guy who just wants to help
people he's probably got a lot of trauma
but adam west i feel like plays that
version just this guy who's an eccentric
billionaire who goes out in gallivants
and fights cry like i believe that in
some ways more than any of the other
ones going for that kind of a vibe he's
not the most tortured batman because
that's not what they're going for and
yet i think he does a really nice job
and i just love watching him that's the
thing is like i really enjoy
genuinely watching his performances no
matter how silly whatever circumstances
might read nowadays so my number four
would actually have to be michael keaton
i really like michael keaton i'm very
excited for his return in the flash
movie especially because of the actor
michael keaton that i grew to love over
time like a lot of my favorite works of
michael keaton are not the batman movies
it's a bunch of his other work what i
love so much about what he does in this
movie in particular is that there's a
kind of subtlety to the darkness
underneath him because it's not like the
most outlandish performance it's not
even the most emotive performance
however what's so cool about what he
does is when he is batman you can also
see that with his version of bruce wayne
there is that thing in those michael
keaton eyes that you want to get nuts
version of him you could feel that
there's that bruce wayne version in
there that is crazy there's a crazy guy
underneath there and i love how if you
just pay attention to the movie you can
feel that but it's done in such a subtle
way the thing that really overshadows
the whole thing for michael keaton is in
both those movies i don't personally
feel like the
character tim burton was most interested
in developing or exploring was batman
it's like you think of batman 89 joker
was the big talk you think of batman
returns it's penguin and catwoman who
are the big talk i feel like if you're
gonna talk about batman he should be one
of the big talks and he had two movies
and he was he didn't seem to be the
thing in the zeitgeist and to this day
he's not the that's most remembered upon
when you think about those films yeah
absolutely and another good segue
because uh my next spot would be michael
keaton for a lot of the same reasons you
mentioned and i do think that yeah once
you get to batman returns especially for
me and you are exploring more of just
again that sort of shared folly you do
the sort of shared psychosis of outcasts
and whatnot the shared struggle of
outcasts like there are things about his
character that are
further illuminated even though yeah i
feel like the movie kind of wants to be
about way other things than bruce or
batman or his personal struggles but
yeah michael keaton just has so much
presence and i love watching him and for
the time he was playing the character uh
you know and originating that more
gritty darker more serious take for the
first time in a big scale you know i
think he really has a lot of presence
that supports that even if the movies
themselves are focused on other things
yeah it's fighting you know it's a
little dated as fighting and also just
michael keaton's bill does feel a little
too skinny for me
i feel kind of like a guy
i don't imagine him working out
so three here's the thing with my top
three i did fluctuate between all three
of them when i just think about it if i
were to have a pass here for a second i
would say they're all equal because they
all bring something different to each
one of the roles in their own way but if
i have to rank them
here it is um so my number three would
have to be christian bale in the dark
knight trilogy i love his performance
one thing that i really love so much
about what christian male has done with
this one is he's able to actually have
like a full character arc he's able to
start off as just bruce wayne
traumatized decides i'm gonna become a
symbol for gotham the city i love and
then has this complete hero's journey
well by the time you get to dark knight
rises he makes the ultimate hero
sacrifice now you actually have a rarity
in the batman world is a full
storyline that is complete with this
three picture deal i think that
christian bale does an excellent job in
each one of them do i think the voice in
the dark knight and the dark knight
rises that he does as batman goes a
little overboard yeah
i do and i think partly why i would put
him as number three even though i do
think he does an excellent job and
batman begins is still my favorite out
of his three performances i think the
voice becomes a bit of a joke more than
just the fact that it's clear he's doing
a voice the duality or segway shift
between bruce wayne and batman i feel
like he's really developed a lot of
bruce wayne and it feels like batman
he's putting on an act for me sometimes
whereas it's supposed to be this is the
real bruce wayne when he's batman this
is the epitome of all his rage and anger
the darkness yet it feels like he's
still doing a performance as him in
those last two films a lot of the time
granted there are some scenes that are
just so perfect for me like the
interrogation scene with him and joker
he is excellent i was just trying to
kind of decipher like why is the voice
thing such a meme why is it so joked
about so much specifically with only his
batman like why him i feel like it might
come down to that even though a lot of
the time in the dark night and the dark
knight rises i'm not that distracted by
it but i think it does become
distracting due to that and in reality i
might just be pinpointing it to that
only because i'm trying to justify a
reason why it's number three really it's
just the emotional impact christian bale
leaves me with is not the strongest out
of the ones i have for number two and
number one at risk of being foolhardy i
guess i would go number two with
christian bale and i almost put him at
number one partly because you do have
that fully arced character or at least
you have all three movies worth to see
him grow to see him you know embody and
and you know learn with this character
and you see you know the the journey
that he goes through with the other
characters like him and alfred are some
of my favorite you know just emotional
beats of those movies and yeah what it
ultimately does come down to for me
anyway is that there are just other
things that are more interesting or that
are you know slightly edging him out in
turn like i think he does a really great
job at holding those movies together and
he does have a lot of presence but there
is something where he's not necessarily
the most interesting person on screen
the most interesting character and i
think it gets really really close and i
do definitely connect with and identify
with him well you see i feel like with
batman begins he is that but with the
dark knight in dark knight rises he's
becomes the less interesting person
there but i do think his bruce wayne is
consistently like one of the best bruce
wayne's ever because of the many
relationships that he has in it so what
i love about those movies is like i
think a lot of the writing and context
around his bruce wayne is really well
developed because i think there's like
three different personas that he
embodies which is the fake bruce wayne
the real bruce wayne when he's like with
michael kane or morgan freeman and then
there's batman and i think that a lot of
the time
what's great about him as a lead is he
uses his performance to elevate the
supporting cast that's a great point and
and even now i'm sitting there going is
that enough reason to bump him
yeah
because it is like and we've been having
kind of a back and forth trying to
figure out exactly how to put the finger
on why and and yeah like i i think there
is something to be said for that
ensemble player who really does provide
the backbone and who does allow the
other performers to shine but two i do
agree like his bruce wayne i think is
probably the most fully formed fleshed
out and does really sell the idea of his
adjustment you see him in those early
stages where he comes back and he almost
shoots joe chill at one point like you
know i feel like he does embody some of
the grief but also the guy who can
clearly function as a public figure
billionaire you know well i think what
they do with his batman though there are
motives about it that i don't agree with
like in dark knight rises how he's just
given up on all this yeah seems like
he's a bit of a weak batman after only a
year and a half he's like a crippled man
all of a sudden yeah there are just
qualities that they do to him that i do
become critical of as a batman fan my
number two would actually have to be and
after re-watching the batman four times
i can now confidently say
that my number two is actually bet
affleck
yeah
um there was a time where i would say
that a batfleck is my number one and
i've seen like bvs and zack snyder's
justice league multiple times i love ben
affleck's batman part of me still wishes
we could get that solo ben affleck movie
make the batflag movie you know what he
does best out of all all the batman for
me personally he is equally magnetic to
me as both bruce wayne and batman i love
his like worn down
more blunt gritty bruce wayne
who's just like
older
and like angrier and his batman is just
this
martial arts ferocity machine who could
take out a whole warehouse full of men
with assault rifles you know and i
really do love that and i think his
progression too from bvs into zack
snyder's justice league where a lot of
zack snyder's justice league is him sort
of making retribution making amends for
who he was in bvs of wanting to do a
hero and do right by superman for not
having believed in him like there's a
lot to his character that i think is
very strong i do like the progression of
his character and i think
that in terms of an equal fitting for
bruce wayne and batman the like like i
think you're the best one-two combo
it's definitely ben affleck for me i
would say that christian bales is my
favorite bruce wayne but in terms of
like the perfect one-two piece it is ben
affleck's uh for me yeah i think he's
just very compelling as both of them
good call thanks for saving the video i
have a very interesting reason for why i
would say who my number one is by the
way
oh you mean our number one our number
one power number one battenson the
addison the robert pattinson batman i
and i was sitting here going is it too
soon to declare this is it full hearty
to on the heels of you know multiple
screenings in you know a couple of weeks
in the whole you know air of excitement
that everyone's had is it too soon to
say that but the more i've seen it and
the more i've thought about it it's a
unique experience for me with a batman
movie because he is perhaps the most
engrossing person on screen like every
choice he makes is fascinating and i
love the idea as much as it seems to
upset some people that he's not
billionaire playboy yet i really liked
his more twisted more tortured more emo
kid take on the character because that
makes a lot of sense for what age they
put him at and what point in his batman
career their take uh you know picking up
from yeah i think he just brought such a
presence and while a lot of people don't
think that there is much difference
between him and batman i would agree
that there is the probably thinnest line
between the two i still found nuances
that are only there when he is just
bruce with alfred versus when he's bruce
alone but as batman versus as batman
around other people whether that be
gordon or criminals or whatever yeah it
is a unique experience to have a batman
movie where the first thing everybody
wants to talk about is bruce is batman
is that performance i really think that
he just knocked it out of the park in
terms of creating a living emotionally
resonant character who fits you know
everything you associate with being
quintessential comic book batman i would
uh i would agree with all that obviously
here's what really dawned on me on my
fourth time of watching this movie and
why i was like you know what i think he
is my favorite batman like batman he's
not my i don't dislike his bruce wayne i
completely understand the choice and i
overall enjoy the choice of having his
bruce wayne be the way it is and i think
it works just right for that particular
movie i still think we need a little bit
more of him as bruce wayne before i can
officially declare like i love his bruce
his batman though it hit me in the
moment when he's going through uh the
penguins nightclub the iceberg lounge i
used to distinguish kind of the
difference between robert pattinson as
bruce wayne robertson as batman was this
was that like when he's just robert
pattinson you just see the boy bruce
wayne just in an adult body which is
reclusive and doesn't want to be around
people you know kind of like that weird
brother in wedding crushers
that's kind of what he is but when he
was going through the nightclub i
realized oh no that boy is still there
and i think that's what really dawned on
me the fourth time i watched this film
is that he carries the boy in the
alleyway throughout that entire
performance that is the day batman was
born
was the day his parents died and in that
entire performance
when he is in the bat suit he's just a
rageful boy it's the game face yeah he's
the boy with the game like when a boy
play it's like that isolated psychotic
little boy who doesn't know how to
really socialize but is really
intelligent really observant and has a
lot of unresolved anger it was like kind
of dark not reclusive non-emotive but
can let it all out through rage picking
on the bullies and the bad guys and
stuff getting his revenge like it feels
like just a really intelligent rageful
boy who translates into the dark
detective throughout that film so when
watching his performance of like even
how he reacts to the cops and reacts
when he feels like gordon might have
betrayed him when he's caught in the
interrogation room he just remains a boy
the whole time and i'm like damn that's
batman
there's always a thing there where i
feel like the performers that try to
make batman be like the man like
batman's a man and which he is like
physically he's a man he's a billionaire
man but i think what robert pattinson
does is he carries that pain throughout
the performance constantly and he
carries that underneath the suit and
through the anger and that's where you
feel the anger comes from and so that's
why i personally would say that he is my
favorite batman well i think every other
batman has to some degree an element of
they want you to relish in the bruce
wayne and almost aspire to be
certain elements of bruce wayne whereas
robert pattinson's does not have any of
that like you can identify you can
sympathize and are sometimes horrified
by what he's going through but he
doesn't have that quality where you're
like but he's also pretty cool you know
yeah you're not gonna see him cruising
down the street in the lamborghini just
yet you know making a joke or whatever
and i like that as well they let that
distance be there between you and him
he's like the boy who just doesn't feel
like he belongs or fits in anywhere who
distances himself from people and so
that's why all he knows how to do is
instill the feelings that he feels and
just evoke fear and then by the end of
the movie he's learning how to connect
like like a hurt boy exactly yeah
it just gets better every time i watch
that movie specifically what he's doing
as a character and i think that's why
having that bruce wayne be that specific
way works because there's not much of a
difference the only difference is when
he's not in the outfit when he's not in
the cowl he's not scary or intimidating
but when he is in the cow he's
terrifying because that's what he is
underneath well and when he is under the
cow there is some sense of direction and
some sense of investment whereas when
he's just bruce you get the sense that
he doesn't really care to be alive and
that's why his and that's why riddler
too paul danno is also an angry child
who just wants family and love
so yeah i think the performance all
around of him is great because for all
the reasons i said and and more that
we've talked about in other videos as
well and it gives you faith that
whatever we see next will be just as
rich and will expound upon the character
in meaningful ways
yeah
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here that was our batman list
catch you guys soon